hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo mi
nombre es juliette reaño y los saludo
desde casa
[Música]
en 2015 el mundo enfrenta una profunda
crisis de refugiados al menos 68 5
millones de personas huyeron de sus
hogares en busca de seguridad e imágenes
impactantes recuerdan lo que fue el
éxodo durante ese año en medio de la
incertidumbre para miles de desplazados
el deporte envió un mensaje de inclusión
y esperanza cuando el comité olímpico
internacional anunció la formación del
equipo de atletas refugiados en 2016 10
deportistas provenientes de etiopía
sudán del sur y república democrática
del congo compitieron en los juegos de
río 2016 para los juegos olímpicos de
tokio serán 29 los deportistas de
refugiados de 11 países que competirán
en el mismo equipo y por primera vez un
atleta latinoamericano está en la lista
el boxeador venezolano el dick's ella
competirá junto a otros refugiados
veamos la historia de otros refugiados
que conformarán el equipo en el informe
de natalia plazas
luna solomon arriesgó su vida cruzando
el desierto libio y luego el mar
mediterráneo antes de convertirse en
refugiada en suiza ahora es uno de los
29 miembros del equipo olímpico de
refugiados abundó con 11 sano jeremic
antes de empezar con el rifle nunca tuve
la esperanza de participar en los juegos
olímpicos ni que mi clima pero cuando mi
entrenador me dijo eso fue un milagro
para mí como
la joven de 27 años huyó de eritrea y
llegó a suiza en 2015 tanto para su
entrenador como para ella es poco
probable regresar a casa con una medalla
sin embargo creen que es más importante
inspirar con su trayectoria quiero creer
que hay historias increíbles e
inspiradoras de atletas que no se
acercan al podio y tal vez algún día
sería genial tener a algún niño
apuntando a la televisión y que diga yo
quiero ser esa chica y que esa chica no
sea una medallista olímpica
pues ansa la maná ya era boxeador cuando
llegó a alemania en 2012 compitió por su
país siria en los olímpicos de londres
pero los bombardeos y la guerra lo
obligaron a abandonar su país ahora
lucha por algo más grande sí lo estoy
boxeando para todo el mundo hay
refugiados en todo el mundo y por eso
estoy boxeando para todos los refugiados
boxeo para muchos países no sólo para
uno
[Música]
y no es el único la iraní que me alisa
de ganó el bronce de taekwondo en río
2016 pero huyó a alemania tras sentir
que era utilizada como una herramienta
de propaganda en su país
obtuvo el estatus de refugiada en
alemania tras recibir ofertas para
competir por países bajos canadá bélgica
y bulgaria ahora valora poder
concentrarse en el deporte sin tener
presiones externas
cuando tu mente está tranquila y no
tienes nada en tu mente puedes entrenar
mucho mejor puedes concentrarte en tu
competencia y ahora todo está bien ahora
lo importante es que puedo combinar mi
vida personal y mi deporte personal life
and sport life ticket en línea como luna
y west ham competirá con una bandera
blanca en los juegos olímpicos de tokio
bandera que más allá de un país
representa a los más de 82 millones de
personas en todo el mundo que se han
visto desplazadas de su hogar a causa de
múltiples conflictos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en otros equipos olímpicos hay
entrenadores migrantes
el boxeo francés vio la sorpresa en los
pasados juegos de río de janeiro
conquistó seis medallas y se coronó como
el deporte que más presea le entregó a
francia
ahora el equipo va a tokio bajo la
dirección del cubano luis mariano
gonzález un migrante que cosecha frutos
en el boxeo francés el informe es de
erika olavarría
cuatro boxeadores hombres y una mujer el
entrenador cubano de la selección
francesa de box ya sabe con los
efectivos que cuenta para ganar espera
al menos tres medallas en los juegos
olímpicos de tokio una de oro una de
plata y una de bronce el co beat que
obligó a anular el mundial que debía
realizarse en francia le hizo también
reducir sus expectativas de clasificados
a la mitad pues yo pienso que
clasificamos lo que tienen que
especificar los mejores nosotros eran se
pueden clasificar pero no tienen
oportunidad de medalla
antes del coi luis mariano he estado
trabajando sin descanso en el gimnasio
destinado al box en el insep el
instituto del deporte francés esas
instalaciones fueron una suerte de
recompensa tras los juegos olímpicos de
río donde fuera de todo pronóstico no
fue la natación sino el boxeo la
disciplina que más preseas conquistó
para francia seis medallas dos de oro
dos de plata y dos de bronce
en 14 años que lleven francia luz
mariano le cambió la cara al box francés
sus pupilos parecen bailar literalmente
sobre el ring
desde 2013 que trabajo con él cada vez
que vamos al extranjero los otros
entrenadores internacionales no miran
para ver cómo trabaja es un placer
tenerlo en nuestro equipo
mariano es una escuela cubana bailamos
con el box lo pueden haber visto en mis
movimientos no se trata de sólo ser un
boxeador lineal y quedarse quieto
la cadencia cubana parece darle vida al
estructurado box galo lo que todos
esperan es que el ritmo dure hasta japón
el camino hacia una vida mejor de 29
deportistas que empezó cuando tuvieron
que huir de sus hogares alcanza un
peldaño más el próximo 23 de julio
cuando la antorcha olímpica sea
encendida en tokio hasta que inmigrantes
de france24 comenten en nuestras redes
con el hashtag migrantes cv24 y sigan
con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]